[MUSIC PLAYING]
DIVYA PILLAI: Today I am proud
to present accordionist Cory
Pesaturo and even prouder to
say that I know him personally.
He's sort of a habitual pioneer
as an American accordionists,
the first graduate from The New
England Conservatory of music
in accordion, a four time
world championship winner
and hopefully
world record holder
in marathon accordion playing.
He just came back from
Austria after having
played for over 32 hours
to break the Guinness World
record.
He's won world championships
on both acoustic and electronic
accordion, and the
only person to also win
a world championship in jazz.
He's got a whole host
of other activities,
including developing his
own electric accordion,
compiling hurricane
weather records,
and collaborating with the
Red Bull Formula One team.
He will discuss the history
of the accordion in America
and what he's doing to
reinvent the instruments.
There's some really interesting
technology involved.
With him that is fellow
accordionists Ljubinka Kulisic,
a Serbian accordionist
and a very accomplished
international performer.
They will both demonstrate their
amazing virtuosic and sometimes
improvisational playing styles.
Please join me in
welcoming Corey Pesaturo.
[APPLAUSE]
CORY PESATURO: All right.
How is everybody
doing today at Google?
It's my first time over here.
It's quite awesome.
And San Francisco is my
favorite city in the world,
so it just works fabulously.
And I guess hello to all of
live streamers and future people
on YouTube.
So does anybody play
accordion in here?
I know Debbie was saying there
are some-- yeah, OK, wow.
All right.
That's more than most, usually.
So we have some.
Usually in a crowd
of 10,000 there
might be one person
that raises their hand.
So this is a pretty
good percentage.
Yeah, so I've been
playing accordion
since I was about
nine years old.
I'm from Rhode Island, that
little tiny state of course.
Started playing
accordion because my dad
played back when it was popular.
And I'll go over the
history of the accordion
and where we're at now.
But let me just play
you a couple of things,
maybe starting with something
you might expect on accordion
and then go through
to stuff you would not
expect on the accordion, because
this is an electric accordion.
And I'll explain the differences
between acoustic and electric.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So yes, you've heard Party Rock
Anthem on the accordion today.
All is good.
Pretty much anything
is possible, really,
on the accordion.
So where to start
with the accordion?
There's kind of still
debate and I don't know.
It's tough trying to research
everything and figure out
when did the accordion start and
when did it get into the phase
that it is in now?
And there are many different
kinds of accordions,
which I'll also say.
So around the 1820s,
1830s, accordion
began as just something
to have an organ
that you'd be able to
almost put in your pocket
and walk around with.
And the idea was to have
these little reeds that you
would play and blow into.
Organetto was kind
of the first one.
And then they started
to look kind of like,
if anybody knows a
bandoneon or concertina
they play in Argentina, they
started to look more like that.
And then around 1900,
people started saying,
why don't we put a
piano on the right side?
And so the actual term of this
instrument that I'm playing
is called the piano accordion.
And that has mainly become
popular in the United States.
And it's kind of interesting
how every single country plays
a different accordion, and I'll
draw different ones that we do.
So the guy that made the
accordion popular in the United
States was a person
named Guido Deiro.
And he came to the United
States in 1908, brought
the first piano accordion.
And that was in
the vaudeville era
and he became a
huge star in that.
And by 1920 accordion was a
fairly popular instrument.
And it stayed that
way until about 1930.
And the accordion
began to die off
as it had its kind of
a little bit of a rain.
And kind of just
stayed in the, it
wasn't unpopular it just wasn't
really a thing to do, probably
until 1948 when Dick Contino
went on the Horace Heidt
show, which in those days
was kind of like American
Idol on the radio.
And he made the accordion
massively popular at that time.
And that stayed
through the '50s,
until 1962 when
the Beatles landed,
and then that was a
quick, a very quick end
to the accordion.
People tell me if you wanted
to be cool in 1960 or so,
you played the accordion.
And by 1965 you couldn't get a
date if you played accordion.
So it was an incredible,
really quick drop off.
But during that time,
especially in the '50s,
there were so many
accordion players
around the United States
and they were just
empires of teaching facilities.
In Detroit there was
Tony Dannon's empire.
You had Joan Sommers
in Kansas City.
You had the AAA organization
in the east coast.
And there were just thousands
of students playing accordion.
We produced a lot of world
champions in the '50s
and into the '60s.
But since the early '60s,
the accordion really died
and by the '80s,
I mean, you didn't
mention the word accordion.
It was just absolute no, no.
Weird Al kind of
came out and used it
as a joke a bit in, what,
probably around the '80s.
But it was still
pretty much a joke.
And it died to the point
where it's almost a good thing
because the younger
generation doesn't
know what the
accordion is today,
because their parents are
the ones that really didn't
want to talk about
it, especially
their parents' generation.
So no one mentioned accordion.
So to young people it's
like, what is this thing?
Yeah, the accordion.
It doesn't have the
negative stigma.
I can say just when I was
growing up the negative stigma
was everywhere.
It was, oh, accordion,
yeah, yeah, the squeezebox,
the polka.
[POLKA MUSIC]
And there's a lot of great
polka accordion players
but that was kind of the joke.
But now I'm seeing it as,
the negative stigma is gone
and it's just becoming this,
what is this instrument?
So that's where we are.
But every country's
history of the accordion
is completely different.
Brazil, right now,
you play accordion,
that's a very cool thing to do.
Argentina, bandoneon,
very cool thing to do.
France, playing accordion,
Finland as well,
all of Scandinavia.
Russia is very big
on classical music.
And you'll see
Ljubinka in a bit.
She's from Serbia.
Serbia, playing accordion,
very cool thing to do.
It's country by country.
In Italy, everybody thinks--
you know, and I'm
Italian, as you
can tell by the hair, nose,
and height, of course,
and that I play accordion.
Everybody thinks, oh, Italian,
yeah, it's very popular there.
No, it's kind of like here.
You ask kids in Italy,
you play a accordion?
No, my grandfather does.
So that is kind of the same.
It depends on the country.
So let me go over-- everybody
understands piano, yes?
So the bellows,
how do they work?
Basically an accordion, not
this because it's electric,
but an acoustic accordion
basically works as a harmonica.
In fact in Italian,
the accordion's
called the fisarmonica.
All it is is these
big harmonicas
that you can actually pull
them out and play them.
And they just all
have reeds on them.
And they are put here and here.
And they're connected to
the air in the bellows
and they're connected
to the keys.
And when you hit a note what
happens is, the hammer opens.
And then when you pull air
through that reed plays.
So that's really--
it's just a harmonica
with a lot of buttons on it,
pretty much-- many harmonicas.
And the different registers
here just have different sounds.
So if I just go to a straight
accordion here, and just
play a note.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's different reed
blocks that would
be being used to make
different sounds,
because if you have four
different reed blocks
you can make a bunch of
combinations with those reeds.
And it's the same on the
left hand with these.
This being electric,
there are no reeds.
It's all computer chips.
You guys being engineers
would know more about how
this works probably than I do.
It's just a lot
of computer chips.
But it's the same basic idea
except here instead of me just
playing my accordion note
when I go to these sounds,
[PIANO NOTES] and I have
a piano, or an organ,
[ORGAN NOTES] or a violin,
[VIOLIN NOTES] and different
things like this.
So the left hand, though.
Let me draw out the
left hand because it's
a bunch of buttons.
This one says, as you saw,
CPes, because Cory Pesaturo,
it's kind of a
shortened name, I guess.
My hip hop name, I don't know--
CPes.
So how do the buttons work?
All right, where are
the markers over here?
Since we have some
accordion players
how many people have somewhat
of a grasp of music theory?
That's a fair amount.
Yikes, all right.
Fair amount, this is good.
I hate explaining the left
hand of the accordion,
because then people go, oh,
that's not that complicated.
I like everyone to look at
it and go, how in the world
do you play that?
Well, it's not too bad.
So if I just draw a cross
section of one line this way
and one line this
way, then you can see.
We'll just do C.
Everybody likes C.
If I go this way, up and
down, what is happening
is over here you would have
G, over here you'd have D,
and this way you'd have F,
this way you'd have B flat,
and it just keeps
going on and on and on.
So this is the--
anybody?
AUDIENCE: Circle.
CORY PESATURO: Circle.
Circle of fifths,
circle of fourths.
I always have called it the
line of fourths and fifths
because it's in a line,
but also musically it
does go on forever.
And you can get to
D quadruple sharp
and you know, E quadruple
flat if you just keep going.
And the thing is,
yes, they do repeat.
So if I go down--
I'll put this in there.
If I go down to D flat here,
I do have F sharp up here.
I mean, what did I say?
D-flat down here,
C-sharp over here.
So there is going to be repeats.
The top row is simply--
I should do this--
is just the third.
So it just gives
you another option.
So C is--
C, E is here, and E of
course is over here as well.
It's the same ones.
So they do repeat.
Now, this would be B.
This would be F sharp.
This would be A.
And this would be D.
So it's just kind of shifted.
Now the top two rows
are single notes.
So a major scale, but you
only have the top [INAUDIBLE]..
[SCALING NOTES]
So you just have
these to play scales.
All below this
continuing in the line,
you have C major, C minor,
C seven, And C diminished.
So you guys will see
if I can do this.
[INAUDIBLE]
[NOTES]
So C in C major, C in C minor,
C in C seven, C in C diminished.
So it's all in this line.
And then if I go to G,
it's the same thing here.
[NOTES] And if you keep
going to D, [NOTES]..
So it's pretty much,
you're just-- you're always
thinking in this line.
where am I on the
left hand of the mix?
And then you can mix and match.
So if you play C major
and G major together,
[NOTES] you get a--
I don't know, for
the theory people
in here-- a C major nine chord.
[NOTES] So you can
mix and match chords.
But this system
was devised really
to get rid of stride piano.
If anybody plays stride piano,
it is incredibly difficult
to go doo, doo, doo,
doo, doo, doo, doo.
So instead of doing that, this
is [NOTES] much much, much
easier is that.
The problem with this is when I
play jazz and play bass lines,
I only can use the top two
rows to play bass lines.
So that gets a little
difficult. And this
is all within one octave.
So this is why if I keep
going up the scale--
[SCALING NOTES]
--I'll just keep
circling and circling.
And it's the same
with all the chords.
All the chords are
within one octave.
But this gives you
at least an idea
of what is going on
on the left hand.
Not that complicated, right?
You know, you have
some theories.
It's not that bad.
Now this is the only problem.
What I just showed you is
called the stradella system
on the left hand, which
is one of many systems
that are used in
the accordion world.
There are many different
kinds of accordions.
So if you have--
let me just, bellows,
OK, whatever.
I'm definitely not an artist.
If you have a keyboard and
a stradella based system
like this one, this is
played in the United States,
in Italy, in Brazil, in
Scotland, half of Russia,
things like that.
Now if you get rid
of this and you
put buttons, which is
what Ljubinka plays,
which we'll get to
her in a minute.
You have buttons here.
This is played in the other half
of Russia, is played in France,
is played in Finland and
Sweden and these places.
But there's many different
systems that this is.
In Finland, actually,
speaking of Finland,
they have their
own button system.
So they can't really-- they have
to travel with their accordion.
They can't just go to
Austria and go play
because it's a totally
different system.
There's a B system, a C
system, different systems.
On the left hand,
there is also free base
where, remember how I said the
top two rows were single notes?
Well, on a free base, all of
the buttons are single notes.
There are no chords.
That is played pretty
much all of Russia,
it always plays this, the
Eastern European countries
play a lot of this.
All for classical
music, especially,
because you can read
piano music directly
onto the accordion with
a free bass system.
But then the other thing is,
what if we change the bellows?
On my instrument when
I play C this way--
let me get rid of the violin--
and I come in, it's
still C, right?
C, C, it doesn't matter.
On a diatonic accordion,
there's buttons here.
And when I play this button
out, when I come in it's
a different note.
That's a diatonic accordion.
That is what you will see
Mexicans play, or Irish play.
It's funny, Scotland
plays piano accordion.
Irish mostly plays
diatonic accordion.
Amazing how that works.
Brazil plays this accordion.
Argentina plays the
bandoneon, which is
more like this with the bellow.
So every country is completely
different on which accordion
they play, unlike piano.
You play piano in Alaska
or you play in Antarctica,
it's a piano is a
piano, or a trumpet.
This is totally different.
So there's so many different
kinds of accordions.
And all of us pretty
much can play one or two.
I can't play "Mary Had a Little
Lamb" on Ljubinka's right side
or left side.
I can't play "Mary
Had a Little Lamb"
on the diatonic instrument.
They're all
completely different.
But everyone thinks
oh, accordion!
You know-- not quite.
So a little lesson in accordion.
So now, to show a
different accordion,
let's bring Ljubinka up.
All the way from Serbia,
ladies and gentlemen.
[APPLAUSE]
She is in town because there is
actually the funnest, biggest,
and best accordion
festival that happens
in the United States
is only about an hour
and a half from here.
So it's in Cotati.
And they have a
whole folk festival
of accordions, different bands
with accordions or different
accordion players.
And I've been bringing
all these friends
I know from Europe that, they
haven't been to the United
States before, that want to
come play the United States
and show different accordions
and different styles
and everything.
So Ljubinka's coming
in to play at Cotati.
And also this other
girl, Tia, from Finland
is coming in to SFO today.
We're going to grab
her and go to Cotati.
So it's kind of a world
meet a different accordion
players playing different
styles and different things
on different accordions.
Actually, her accordion will
be different from yours,
different from mine.
So there you go.
But they all have bellows.
That's all that matters.
So Ljubinka, what are
you going to play?
LJUBINKA KULISIC: I'm
playing a second movement
of the Bulgarian Suite
from Vyacheslav Semoyonov,
Russian composer.
And it's free base.
So you can hear free base.
[MUSIC - BULGARIAN SUITE, SECOND
MOVEMENT]
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, OK, I can play one more.
This comes after,
third movement.
[MUSIC - BULGARIAN SUITE, THIRD
MOVEMENT]
[APPLAUSE]
CORY PESATURO: Ljubinka Kulisic!
Anybody know what
rhythm that was in?
AUDIENCE: Eleven.
CORY PESATURO: Ah-ha!
All right.
You've really brought some
musicians in the house.
Eleven, yes!
All right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CORY PESATURO: Oh, really?
[INAUDIBLE]
All right, eleven, look at that.
We're getting three
accordionists in here
and people [INAUDIBLE].
This is an awesome audience.
Need to come here more often.
So all right, now the
question, why do I
have a flame crazy accordion
that also has lights,
which we'll get to in a second?
So my goal really
from, I don't know,
really from when
I started playing,
was that I wanted to make
the accordion cool again
because since 1962 or so really,
it just hasn't-- it's been
laughed and made fun
of, blah, blah, blah.
And it's such an
amazing instrument.
It's the only instrument you
can play as many-- really more
notes-- as a guitar or piano.
But also we can
play with the sound.
Once you hit a note on
the guitar or piano,
you're kind of
done on the volume.
But on accordion, [NOTES]
you can manipulate the sound
constantly.
It's also portable,
which is nice.
So you can walk around and
play and do other things.
Not the funnest to
go on a plane with.
That becomes problems at times.
It must go above.
It cannot go below, obviously.
But it's just an
amazing instrument.
It's known around the world to
play so many different genres.
I do literally play
techno at college parties.
But then the next day
I'm playing background
Italian music for a wedding.
So you can do anything with it.
But in trying to make
it cool, my first goal
was to attain a
world championship
and try to get some
notoriety for it
in the United States
press and such.
And every time I come
back for a championship,
I might get an article in Rhode
Island paper or something.
Nothing would happens.
I'd say, OK, well, you've
got to do more than this.
So then I said-- and of course,
I'm playing electric accordion.
I tried to do
America's Got Talent.
They made fun of it.
No, didn't work,
because it's still
cool to hate the
accordion somehow.
But all right, so
how about I skin it
and have the first ever skinned
accordion with some kind
of a flame thing on it.
So I did that.
As you can tell, I
play it around here
apparently more
than anywhere else,
because I need to
replace some of these.
So then I said, OK, well,
I had a crazy engineer--
as he calls himself, a
freelance mad scientist--
do some lighting
stuff, as you can see.
So it's all symmetrical
lighting system
that goes with everything here.
Depends on the octave where the
lights are, but no matter what
I play it's always symmetrical.
I should actually practice
like what things spell out
a word or something.
But I don't know,
never done that.
[INAUDIBLE]
So don't just constantly
trying to do things.
Then the Guinness World
record idea came up.
And I do stuff with--
because I'm a huge
motorsports person.
That's it's almost like, that's
not my hobby, that's my life
and this is just my hobby.
And I'm from Boston,
so of course, you
know, big sports
person in general.
But I said, well, why not try to
break a Guinness World record?
So they set up a whole thing
and I'm playing a concert
in Austria next week that's
associated with Red Bull.
So they said well,
we'll justify it
and you know market
the festival and I
went and did 32
hours and 14 minutes
and I thought my hand was going
to fall off and strangle me.
It seems to be OK for now.
But now I've come back, trying
to push it in the press,
say, yes!
I have a world
championship, world record.
Just trying to always get
notoriety on the accordion
and make this something
that kids might want
to be interested in to learn
how to play, instead of mommy,
I want to play guitar,
I want to play drums,
I want to play piano.
I want to play accordion!
Which we have some
in here, so yes,
there is some accordion love.
But now Ljubinka playing
acoustic accordion,
those are all real
reeds you were hearing,
where this is all
computerated sound.
The fun part about
this, musically,
is that not only do I have the
pull sensitivity, of course,
of the bellows, but I also
have the touch sensitivity.
And the best patch on here
to show the touch sensitivity
is the doo-wop patch, which
is my favorite I must say.
[NOTES] Things like this.
So yeah, there's little
people inside my accordion
there, thanks.
So if I just touch it
lightly I can manipulate it
like an accordion.
But if I hit it harder, [NOTES],,
or if I hit it really hard,
[NOTES].
So it depends on the touch.
So I usually try to do a
different tune every time
I do something on this.
One I've never done,
so this should be fun,
but everybody loves this
tune, the Super Mario Bros.
Theme.
So we can do that
on doo wop sounds.
Why not?
Let's see.
Never done this one.
This will be interesting.
I'll play around with it though
and improvise some of it.
[MUSIC - SUPER MARIO BROS THEME]
[APPLAUSE]
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Who, when they woke
up today thought,
I'm going to hear Mario
Brothers theme doo-wops
on an electric accordion?
Even I didn't.
I don't know.
Never did that.
Let's see, what else
here just to go over
before we get to
different questions,
because I know
you guys are going
to have all random questions on
accordion and everything else.
But let me do one more
different tune here--
capabilities of this.
On the percussion sounds on
this particular instrument,
they are-- a lot of
people think I'm always
playing with drum
tracks and things
like this from a computer,
which you actually can.
I have a USB inside and I can
actually just kind of play
tunes, anything that I want.
It's like, I've used this
at a party for a boom box.
My own instrument, which
is kind of interesting.
You know, you do
something like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Something I recorded before.
So it's nice because
when I'm traveling
if the TV needs like a
bump out for something,
can you just make up some
French thing, or Italian thing,
or whatever, tango thing,
for no copyrights, you know.
I can be in my hotel room and
someone can be talking to me
and I can still be recording and
get the USB out and send it off
and we're good to
go, which is really
cool to have that on board.
But the drum sounds,
though, they are all
real of what's going
on over here, even when
I did the techno thing.
[DRUM BEATS] So it's
touch sensitive again.
[DRUM BEATS]
I am playing it.
If I got rid of everything,
[NOTES] just be an accordion.
And then the wind, yeah.
[WIND BLOWING] That
depends if I hold it.
It has a wind on there.
There's also thunderstorms,
and you know.
At sound checks, I love
doing the thunderstorm sound
in a sound check because
then the people freak out
like what's going on?
So let's do something
from not too
long ago that I think
everybody knows.
This'll be kind of fun
with the drum sounds.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, so we can open up
the floor here to questions.
We want to hand out
the other mic, I think?
DIVYA PILLAI: Just to get
started, there's one--
CORY PESATURO: Oh,
question over here!
DIVYA PILLAI: There
is one question on--
so we have a dory.
If you haven't seen it
yet, the GoLink for that is
go/accordion-dory.
So we have one question
from that, from Denise.
Congrats on breaking the
Guinness World record
in marathon accordion playing.
How did you train for it?
CORY PESATURO: Oh boy.
The answer is, I
didn't train for it.
I just-- I have a
knack for just kind
of winging a lot of things.
My most known
world championship,
which is an acoustic accordion,
I couldn't bring my accordion
on the plane.
Like I was saying,
it's always a problem.
So I just grabbed one there
and they were like, here,
you just choose accordions.
I was going to wear
an all white outfit
and I saw a white accordion.
I was like, ah, I
got it, that one.
It matches.
It has-- they went,
don't you want to try it?
Yeah, no, I got to use that one.
You know, and I had fun do that.
But won that.
The Guinness record
I said, eh, if I--
I was going to do a
17 hour practice run
and see how I felt
after 17 hours,
write down notes and say,
OK, maybe I should do this.
I should have my arm here,
maybe blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I said why even
use the energy?
I'm just going to use all
the energy at the event.
Just go there and go for it.
And that's kind of what I
did because it's all mental.
Your body stops at
hour 10 or 12 and says
I can't do this anymore.
My arm was sending all these
awful feelings and signals
to my hands to stop.
But my mind was like, nope!
Have to keep going.
Must keep going.
It's all mental.
You've just got to
push through it.
So, yeah, really the
answer is actually nothing.
DIVYA PILLAI: Good answer.
Any questions from the audience?
All right.
CORY PESATURO: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like the end of the race, I
have the official questions.
AUDIENCE: So what does an
accordion world championship
consist of?
Like what does that mean?
How do you win one?
CORY PESATURO: So they're just
like piano or cello or violin
competitions.
There's usually a panel
of about eight judges.
Some of them have rounds.
Like the one I was just saying
with the white accordion,
they had three different rounds.
And they usually have
national champions
from different parts
of the world that
go to one of two main
competitions that
happen every year.
And actually I'm trying to
get the world championships
to happen in the United States,
either LA or Boston, in 2020.
Trying to bring that
here because it goes
to different places every year.
But it's just like
any other competition.
They have a big panel of
judges that look very serious
and you're nervous.
And there's
different categories.
There's classical
category and then
there's more of a overall
variety kind of category.
So just kind of like
any other instrument.
DIVYA PILLAI: Any
more questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
CORY PESATURO: Hi!
AUDIENCE: Amazing
playing, first of all.
CORY PESATURO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I am really
impressed by what
you've been doing and described
and demonstrated today.
You are pushing the accordion
as a solo instrument.
Do you also play in
ensembles and if so what
do you envision as sort of the
future direction of accordion
as an ensemble instrument
and interactions
with other accordions
or other instruments?
CORY PESATURO: Well I mean,
I'm more known as a jazz guy
than anything else.
So I, of course, prefer
to play with people.
And there's always
a kind of a problem
amongst accordion
players that, because we
can do so much on our own,
we play alone gigs of lot
because people can
hire us as like almost
a trio with the left hand and
everything else, especially
with this.
And it becomes a problem
because you know,
obviously you're a musician,
you don't get good time
when you play alone a lot.
You need to play with other
people to have a nice set time.
The other thing is just
musical ideas and collaborating
with different people--
you know, the
musical interaction,
especially in jazz or
Eastern European music.
You want to be with people.
So I love playing
with musicians.
The problem is I get hired
so much as a soloist.
But it depends.
What I go to Austria,
that will be a trio.
At Cotati there'll be a mix
of things, drummer and such
like that.
But I mean, the accordion
is currently used,
certainly all over the world,
in many different ensembles,
especially in places where
it's still popular like France,
Argentina, and such.
But I don't know what
the percentage would be,
though, of the accordions
used solo or ensemble wise
currently.
It's kind of interesting.
I don't really know.
But any other questions on that?
AUDIENCE: I can do a follow-up
unless anybody else--
CORY PESATURO: Yeah, I mean,
you could follow-up, whatever.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
A follow-up only in the
sense of a second question,
not actually
related to that one.
I'm a violinist, by the way.
I play a lot of
klezmer in Romanian--
CORY PESATURO: Klezmer!
Oh, I play more klezmer
gigs than anything,
actually, because there's
another genre of music where
the accordion is needed,
as well as violin.
AUDIENCE: And as a
violinist, certainly,
many much of the incredibly
virtuosic Romanian music
has [INAUDIBLE] over into
the classical violin as well.
Has that been the
case for accordion?
Or how has the virtuosity
of those styles of music
influenced other areas
of accordion music?
CORY PESATURO: The
accordion is kind of
similar to the violin in the
fact that, I think a lot of--
speaking of Romanian,
in the Balkans
it's like all the best
musicians I've ever heard
seem to be from the Balkans.
Like you know,
whether it's violin,
all my favorite
accordion players
are from, whether it is Serbia,
or Macedonia, or Romania,
Bulgaria especially.
So it's like the folk
root to the classical root
kind of thing, in how they mix.
Usually in the
accordion world it's
pretty separated, like it is
I think in the violin world.
Although some people,
they train as a classical
until they're 18 or something
and then they kind of
branch off into something else.
A lot of violinists I play
with went through that.
I studied a lot
of classical stuff
because as accordion
players, we don't necessarily
have much classical
accordion music.
But we do a lot of transcribing.
I played a lot of Tchaikovsky
and things like this
because it kind of fits
well just on the accordion.
But usually it is, like
with these competitions,
the people that
do the classical,
you don't really see them
doing folk gigs or vice versa.
They're kind of in
separate worlds.
But technique
wise, I don't know.
There is a standard, I'd
say, technique for accordion.
And actually, speaking of
technique, the right hand
piano, and the end button
as well, on accordion
is exactly the same as piano,
the claw kind of thing.
It's really exactly the same.
It's just, it moves, so you
have to kind of move with it.
So I haven't done any show where
I've had to dance or something.
That would be-- but
you see violinists.
I mean, they make you guys do
twirls upside down and things.
So it's not that bad.
And this side is attached.
We have a bass strap here.
So this doesn't really move.
But this is kind of a--
this can be a problem.
And it's 25 pounds,
so not the funnest.
But it's OK.
DIVYA PILLAI: Anymore-- OK.
AUDIENCE: So you said there
all these types of accordions.
How did you end
up with this one?
Are there any other
types you can play?
CORY PESATURO: No, no.
Like I was saying,
the United States
is like 99% piano accordion.
And in fact, if I think quickly
of the two accordionists
I know in the US that
play professionally
that play button accordion,
they came from other countries
to the United States.
It's just, it's a very
border to border situation.
Canada, as well, is pretty much
all piano, when I just learned.
But as soon as you go to Mexico,
it's all diatonic button--
totally different.
Portugal, as well,
is kind of the same.
Ireland the same, like that.
But it's just, yeah,
in the United States
it's always, always
been piano accordion.
And no, I can't
really play anything
on any of the other accordions.
It's totally, totally
a different system.
[DRUM BEAT]
Whoops, sorry.
Let's turn that off.
[NOTES] OK, we're back to
accordion, real accordion.
So no, no, I can't.
As I said before, I can't even
play "Mary Had a Little Lamb"
on any of the other accordions.
I could kind of learn it, but
the speed I would learn it
would be the same speed
like you would learn it.
You know music.
You could kind of
figure out the system.
But everything else
is totally different.
The layout of the left
hand, completely different.
It's not the circle of fifths
and fourths that I showed.
So they're all very different.
DIVYA PILLAI: Questions?
CORY PESATURO: Any
other questions?
DIVYA PILLAI: I have
a question for you.
CORY PESATURO: Oh,
you have a question!
DIVYA PILLAI: Yeah, yeah.
Because you perform in
so many different styles,
I think you were
trained in, I'm assuming
New England Conservatory
was more classical?
CORY PESATURO: No, actually.
DIVYA PILLAI: No?
CORY PESATURO: New England
Conservatory really
opened my ears up
more to more genres
because I played a
fair amount of French.
Of course I grew up
playing Italian music
and classical music
for competitions.
That was mainly a kind of
mix of classical and Italian
and some older pop
kind of things.
But NEC opened me up to Eastern
European music, odd meters,
also you know, Brazilian music.
And I spent a lot of
time learning jazz.
It takes so long to do that.
And then all these
other different genres
around the world.
So no, because NEC has--
what's great about New
England Conservatory,
they have classical,
jazz, like a lot
of different conservatories,
but they also
have contemporary improv.
And the real definition
of contemporary improv
is, anything that's not
classical and jazz, but also
classical and jazz
kind of messed with.
So when I went over there,
they were like well,
we can't put you in
classical or jazz.
But we can put you
in contemporary,
which means I could play
classical music-- we
did a lot of classical music--
and Eastern European music.
But then, you know, it's a lot
of contemporary stuff like,
[MUSIC].
Kind of this modern kind
of things and some of that.
Tapping on the accordion,
different things like this.
And also mixed classical
and jazz, so it was,
I didn't really do much with
the classical department there.
So no, that was
really kind of where
I expanded the genres of what
I could kind of hear and play.
DIVYA PILLAI: I was
going to ask about,
I guess some how
you learned improv
and whether that's
normal, I guess, among--
CORY PESATURO: How
did I learn improv?
DIVYA PILLAI: Yeah.
CORY PESATURO: I've always,
always been an improviser.
Really, I remember a
lesson probably six months
in where my dad had a record
of Charlie Magnante who
is one of the other extremely
important accordionists
in American history.
And there was just this tune I
liked and I would listen to it.
I was learning it
by ear and then
I went in and played
it for my teacher.
And like, what are you
doing learning music
without the sheet music?
You know, I was very
much in trouble.
It really wasn't until
I found jazz I was like,
oh, you're supposed
to improvise!
I like this.
But I've always been
a huge improviser
because it makes the
ability to kind of--
I mean, like what we might
do in a couple of minutes.
I haven't played that song in I
don't know, probably who knows?
Trying to remember
the chord changes.
But it's just an ear thing.
Obviously like
with your question,
there's kind of the
different realms
of teaching where, when you
study for years, especially
the Russians and
Eastern Europeans,
that win most of the world
classical championships
for the past 30 years.
They're practicing six
hours a day or more,
studying heavy duty
classical music
but they can't
improvise anything.
And then there's kind of
the other school of thought.
So it's really, I mean, I see it
the exact same in violin world.
It's the exact same
in piano world.
It's kind of the same idea.
But I think improvisation
is so important.
And just, if I hear
something on the radio,
I'm already kind of learning it.
And then I can maybe go
play it at next set gig,
things like this, if I can
decode it quick enough.
Any other questions?
Or it's La Danza time.
All right.
Let me get that one ready.
AUDIENCE: So with the
different types of accordions--
this is sort of two parts--
how closely do different
layouts of the accordions
align to the underlying
theory or structures
of the music in the
different countries?
CORY PESATURO: That
definitely does.
AUDIENCE: Like is it easier
to play Finnish music
on an accordion that--
CORY PESATURO: Yeah, there
is definitely a bit of that.
Even like the best
example I can think of,
actually, is, this
is close to home.
If you listen to like
certain kind of Tejano music
and different genres
of Mexican music,
where the accordion is
very important in the band,
there's always an
accordion player,
and they play diatonic
which is the one where
you hit one note this
way, it's one sound,
and it's a different
one when you come in.
So it's like when they play,
if they're in the key of G
and they're playing G, you
know, they're playing this.
And then when they play D they
have to go out the whole time.
They have to keep
going out or they
can't play in the key of D.
So there's not many keys you
can play in on a diatonic.
When you listen to that
music, usually there's
not too many ways
and chord changes.
They kind of stay around home.
And you can do that on there.
But there's these licks that
they play, these [INAUDIBLE]
kind of things, that no matter
how good technique I have,
I can't do it as clean
and nice as they do it
because on the diatonic
there's a way they can do it
with that particular instrument.
And the same thing
in Irish music.
They have these
things to replicate
what you can do on a violin
with double stops and such.
And you can do that
easier on a diatonic.
I can't really do that here.
It would never sound as clean
or as nice as a diatonic.
So there is definitely
that aspect to it.
And for classical
music, they mostly
play what Ljubinka
plays because here, I
don't have a big hand either.
I can get like a knife nicely.
This, on a button accordion,
would be two octaves, solidly.
So you can do a lot more
on the button accordion.
It took the accordion world
to figure out, the piano!
That's not a great system.
It's not symmetrical and
it's too-- this sucks.
And they made a whole new system
that's much more advanced.
And it's easier to be able to do
these crazy chord, wide chords
in certain lines and such.
Also, to change key on a button,
if you're playing a song in C
and you want to go to
D-flat you just do this.
You just shift and
it'd be the same.
So that's better.
There are other things
that make it much harder
to play that system,
especially because it
has many more buttons to play
when you're flying around.
But for classical music,
that system is way better.
And if you go to the world
championships for classical,
90% plus play the button
accordion versus this one,
because it's just
very, very hard
to be able to do these
crazier things on piano.
It's just not built for it,
mainly because of the distance
that I have here,
even though they
are smaller than piano
keys as you can tell.
They're a little bit skinnier.
AUDIENCE: And then
the sort of continued
part of that, which
you sort of addressed
there is, hypothetically if you
could design your own accordion
completely from scratch without
any engineering constraints
or anything, like what
would you change or keep
from this current accordion?
And especially with going
to like electric accordion,
are there any
parameters or things
you wish you could control
more finely that you
don't have here?
CORY PESATURO: Well, I mean, the
main problem with accordion--
look wise, the thing I'm
always trying to change just
from a marketing
perspective, why
I've designed this
other accordion that I'm
kind of building with a
different MIT engineer,
is the look of it.
You know, when you play
guitar it just looks cool.
It's light, you can
fly around with it.
And this, I can't do much with.
It's just this big--
someone said it
looks like an air conditioner.
Yeah, it kind of does.
It's like this big--
this is why I've done
all this crazy stuff to it.
So there's kind of
that marketing aspect.
I can't be Jimi
Hendrix jumping around
on stage with this instrument.
So the weight, yeah, the
weight and the look of it
is one thing.
The other aspect is, technical
wise, playing the bellows,
you know, it's weird
playing technique here
when you're moving around.
So it'd be great if the bellows
were some kind of other system.
Like, if it was,
I thought I needed
to have just two separate
parts and maybe there
was a D beam in the middle.
And something to do
with the distance
would actually work
as the bellows,
versus kind of you contained.
So I had some different designs
of what an accordion could be.
Almost like two touchpads kind
of thing, something like this.
Obviously yeah, that system
is kind of a better piano.
But it depends.
I love this particular
system with the left hand,
the stradella
system, because you
can do so many things with it.
It's good enough
for single notes,
and the chords you can
do a lot with that.
So I don't know.
There's definitely a fair
amount I would change.
We all look like this
when we're 90%, of course,
because of the weight.
We all have back problems.
But I don't know.
And then you throw
it on your back
and you go this way when you're
walking through the airport.
So it kind of, in the
end it evens out I guess.
It's not too bad.
How's that?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Sorry, one more thing.
Can you play
microtonal music on--
are there adapted accordions?
CORY PESATURO: No, although I
cannot believe I can't answer
this.
I keep forgetting
to look this up.
I have heard from three
different people in my life.
But I've never seen it.
No one's ever been able to
[INAUDIBLE] the picture.
Apparently in Turkey,
where microtonal music
you see a lot with the
[INAUDIBLE] and such.
What's the scales?
I can't think--
those Turkish scales.
Makams!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There are accordions they
make with semi-tone notes,
and they're split up.
And I've heard this
from multiple people
that they exist.
I have yet to see a picture.
But apparently they
do, because there's
some pretty reputable sources.
So not on this one, although
I can actually come in here
and tweak the tuning
and things like that.
But I can't have certain
notes be different things.
So not this one, no.
But apparently
you can somewhere.
Do we want to do--
since we said how in the
world did we meet at MIT?
I didn't go to MIT.
But I know a lot of people
in music department there.
How many people know Divya
is a fantastic singer?
Oh!
Only a 10th of the room.
What's going on
around [INAUDIBLE]??
OK.
Let's see.
DIVYA PILLAI: I don't know how
this works with the microphone,
because this is opera.
CORY PESATURO: Just sing.
Or to hold it--
I don't know.
DIVYA PILLAI: If there's
feedback, I apologize.
CORY PESATURO: This is the
first version of La Danza?
DIVYA PILLAI: Yeah.
CORY PESATURO: All right, OK.
Let's see.
DIVYA PILLAI: It's all
you in the beginning.
CORY PESATURO: Ah yes, I know.
[MUSIC - LA DANZA]
[APPLAUSE]
CORY PESATURO: Fantastico!
Brava, brava.
All right.
DIVYA PILLAI: Thank you.
CORY PESATURO: All right.
Well, thank you guys so
much for coming out, hearing
some accordion stuff.
And I'll be around
for a little bit,
so if you want to ask
other questions as well,
or the live folks,
you can Facebook
me and all these other things,
ask me whatever questions you
want, be around.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CORY PESATURO: More techno?
OK, we'll end it with
10 seconds of techno.
Yeah, I know.
You've got to give
us more techno.
Give me a key
then, or something.
AUDIENCE: D.
CORY PESATURO: D. Give me--
well, give me another key.
OK, D-- no, no, I
mean, D is good.
I just, give me more.
Give me more.
Start in D. OK, all right.
I love this crowd.
They don't say F-sharp exactly!
I'm waiting for that.
Please no, all right, good.
There's an F-sharp.
OK.
[MUSIC - TECHNO]
[APPLAUSE]
We'll call that the Google
Jam Techno, whatever.
Made it p for you.
All right, thank you so much.
Thank you, Divya,
for putting this on.